I think I'm going insane what I think
this tiny house is making me go insane
and I think the beer will help nothing
like the smell of a house hi I'm Garrett
and I'm Nikki and we're fascinated by
how other people live so we're gonna try
and find some really interesting living
situations and live there experiencing a
totally new lifestyle thing is Nikki I
don't actually really know each other
when do you shower when you wake up when
do you go to bed but we're gonna live
with each other as almost complete
strangers in an actual complete
strangers house this week we're gonna be
living in a tiny house Hey hey Nick
thank you so much for having us this is
a beautiful part of the country the tiny
house was built in April 2016 what
attracted me was the the nice wood
sidings and something that would blend
in with our terrain which is very
country
the deck is basically the same size
footprint as the entire house it allowed
us to have kind of doubled the space
when you have these doors open these
windows open you don't feel so
claustrophobic no that's why I was gonna
say like for such a small space it feels
so open yeah and the vaulted ceiling
helps a lot like I'm six foot seven and
I do not feel cramped yeah okay that's
great how big is it eight by 20 so it's
a hundred and sixty square feet okay the
law could be taller yeah in 2003 we had
a big fire in San Diego in a matter of
minutes we went from having a nice home
to literally nothing people around us
that did lose anything kept looking at
themselves of what would happen if I
lost my things really not that big of a
deal matter of fact I felt liberated
it's got everything that all the plates
and anything you could possibly need you
know all opener that's really all you
that it's a very good use of space yeah
that's I guess you sort of have to huh
every little corner you have to find a
use for a lot of people live in places
of this square footage this is you know
160 square feet is not a lot of space
and this way it gave people an idea of
what they did need and what they didn't
need okay I think I am a good roommate I
keep pretty clean I'm pretty quiet I
like to keep to myself
the only thing is that I'm very big I
have lived with roommates on several
occasions but never more than a year
because I didn't like it finally one of
us needs a privacy curtain and then
private from the other person where's
Garrett from she mentioned that her
parents live in Washington something in
the Midwest like Chicago that feels
right right I don't even know what part
of town Nikki lives in Garrett feels
like the kind of guy who would like
in a big house like a bunch of bees
probably maybe a lady when say Nicky
lives in a two-bedroom apartment with a
roommate I imagine every living
situation for him is too small because
he's huge that I dunno
you would not be able to have sex on the
earth no I don't see how two people
could possibly have sex up here
especially if one we're gay only one
only one is gay people I know that's
that we're trying to see how is for us
to live up here it's impossible I'm
really excited to see what it's actually
like to try to live in a tiny house and
not be able to like escape but again I'm
doing this with a practical stranger
that I work with so ideal scenario I
don't know just always excited to see
how other people live oh man we're
really gonna get to know each other
aren't we we're here for two nights
we've just moved in should we have like
House Rules try and keep your [ __ ]
pretty tidy I keep my stuff pretty tidy
also I've like never lived with a boy
before you haven't I'm bored you're
probably going to be the second girl
that I've ever lived with and never
hooked up with oh also my fiance made
cookies so we have could your what I had
no idea Nikki was engaged don't really
good cookies have you had them I'm gonna
do tonight we should get some booze I
don't drink
you don't drink I don't drink what okay
so we have like no space in here right
we don't have space for this [ __ ]
pinecone it's decorative we like I think
that's rule number one
no [ __ ] decorations like even the
fact that these horse heads are here
they look very nice those should be
extra pots look at you you're starting
to think like a tiny house man Pattaya
has been kind of neat I mean it's so
small like I'm staring at Nikki's bed
right now I'm above our kitchen and
bathroom as much as Nick said he thinks
like a family of four could live in here
that's insane like one person in this
Nihon can't do something without the
other person knowing a lot of forced
intimacy and it's a lot of force time
together so far living with Nikki has
been good she seems like a hard person
to impress Garrett seems to fine so far
like he seems like a pretty chill person
I had basically a full-time job of
playing volleyball and like got to meet
the president because of it wait what
you met Barack Obama yeah wait what yeah
when you were asking about you to meet
the president I'm getting to know Nikki
a little bit better well so like I'm
like a film school dropout okay
I was just one of those people just
didn't do well in college you know okay
I like super didn't fit in but I'm
getting a better sense of who she is and
she's a cool person there's a bug in
here they wanna think I'm gonna wake up
in the middle of the night bash my head
on the ceiling and get knock myself
unconscious no Garrett oops so it's the
morning after day one and last night I
didn't quite pretty well I came outside
to give her privacy because there's
really no other place to go to give her
privacy
last night I realize I forgot to bring
toothpaste so I didn't using Garrett but
I mean like roommates right how'd you do
are you gonna fit in this shower
depending on how high the tub is good
luck Thanks
[Music]
okay
oh my god I don't have any clothes why I
they're all upstairs in my little hovel
how are you because mistakes like this I
know but you could have brought your
clothes into the bathroom that's what I
did you know I feel like you really do
like sacrifice comfort to live in this
space don't you think yeah I'm starting
to get that feeling do you cook
I make the world's best scrambled eggs
what yeah Campbell who told you that
I've told it to me and then every time
I've said to somebody I make the world's
great scrambled eggs nobody's ever said
these are not the best scrambled eggs no
the best returns late for this are you
making excuses already yep yep he's
actually a little overdone usually it's
best with like toast and like some
Tomatoes hope you yeah scramble eggs how
was last night for you oh god that
sounds like we just had sex
[Laughter]
[Music]
tonight we're making chicken wings with
the limes from Nick Street which is
pretty cool I think we gonna become
friends like I think we'll be friends
after this he's not like the type of
person that I like find myself around
all the time I think I might get drunk
tonight I think it's a good idea to get
drunk in your tiny house this is like a
nice relaxing lifestyle of like pick
fruit from your garden put it in the
food that you make eat it it's like very
rewarding so like I get it I've never
been more proud of anything in my life I
can't believe I got this sword really
when I said I would do this I had no
idea what I was doing but it's working
oh look at these crisscross grill marks
I got here
it's like Burger King oh that's pretty
good when I woke up this morning I was
like nervous about what we were gonna do
all day and we ended up filling it
pretty well Nicky I went outside to read
because we thought the Sun was saying it
would be nice to read and we ended up
just talking for like two hours
Geron I may be first spoke to each other
like three months ago and like here we
are like telling each other like what
our dreams for the future are for our
lives I got to FaceTime with her fiance
hello it's so nice to meet you I'm like
not always the best at like meeting new
people in like this one-on-one setting
it's been really nice hey Garrett do you
want to do sheet masks it's so goopy
[Music]
don't know about tiny house living you
just like all everything you're doing is
like this cuz you're like there's like
there a person here or like a wall there
or like stuff here and that there's no
privacy whatsoever I don't know if I
could actually live in this tiny house
even by myself it seems like a crazy
non-starter well yeah we didn't even
have like our clothes here like if I had
more than two days worth of clothes here
I have no idea where I would have put
them Nicki what are you doing Nicki this
house is a it's like 180 square feet as
like a permanent long-term living
situation I just don't think it's for me
no name copy yeah this tiny house
surpassed some of my expectations and
kind of fell short and others working
was really inspirational like you have
this unbelievable view that said because
it was so small and cramped I had to get
out of here like I couldn't work on
anything for more than an hour it's been
nice put two tiny house livers good on
you
I respect your lifestyle bye tiny house
[Music]